this is jaco podcast number 299 with
echo charles and me jocko willing good
evening echo good evening
so there is a video
and it's it's out there
in the world on youtube or whatever
you can find it and it's
it's a video of the battle of ramadi
in 2006 in the summer time and there's
this
big fire fight going on
and you can tell it's pretty intense
there's machine gun fire
a bunch of people
putting rounds down range people are
yelling and barking out orders and
passing information and you can kind of
put together that they're working to get
a bomb dropped
from air support
on
a vehicle
that the insurgents had been utilizing
and fighting from
and
they
they get the bomb run
and right as the right as the bomb is
about to hit there's a lull in the
gunfire because guys are taking cover
you know as that bomb is going to hit
and then so there's a lull in the fire
and then
the bomb hits
and there is a massive explosion
and you hear like a couple hoots and
then you hear
this you hear this bellowing laughter
from one person and you can tell though
the laughter is sort of
it's some surprise it's some excitement
it's some level of relief and some it's
also just some twisted dark military
humor
that's making this person
bellow out with this laughter and
i
watch that video sometimes
and i listen to that video sometimes not
for the firefighter not for the bomb
drop
but to hear that laugh
that laugh is coming from seth stone
and you don't see him on camera
but if you knew seth
then that laugh is unmistakable
and that's what i like to hear
and that's reflective of life
because seth was
[Music]
he was tough and he was brave and he was
smart and he was creative and he was a
combat leader
but above all those
characteristics
what i like to remember most about him
now
now that he's gone is his laugh
and humor
is a blessing and laughter is an
antidote to pain and
suffering
and anguish and sometimes it's the only
relief for those things
i have another friend who once told me
everybody's got their vietnam
and in this particular case he was
talking about the fact that his first
girlfriend when he was a kid
was older than him and was bigger than
him and she would just pick him up and
kiss him against his will and there
wasn't anything he could do about it and
so he just had to deal with it
he just had to get through it
everybody's got their vietnam
he told me
and he wasn't in vietnam nor was he even
a veteran
but he was just adding humor
to life
but there is some truth to that
statement
everybody struggles in life
and those struggles vary some struggles
we face are imposed on us by the world
some struggles we face are imposed on us
by ourselves
they also vary in intensity and
consequence and depending on who you are
when it's your problem when it's your
struggle that's the world
and as was with seth
one of the best ways to overcome
struggle is humor comedy
and that same friend of mine
certainly has used humor to get through
his life
let's get through some of his struggles
and some of those struggles more severe
than just getting kissed by a seventh
grader his name is theo vaughn and he's
here with us tonight to share some of
his struggles
and some of the lessons he's learned
in making everyone laugh as a comedian
in order to overcome those struggles
that we all face
theo theovonne
thanks for coming by man good to be here
man thank you guys for having me um
what's going on yeah i'm sorry to hear
about mr stone man i didn't know that
guy but
definitely i never been through anything
like
basmati
you know i mean i've had their rice i
guess i don't even know what i've had
i think i don't know i mean i yes i have
had it and i think i'm gonna say i have
and that's actually one of my favorite
i like a lot so basmati is a kind of
rice i think it is echo confirmed i i
can neither come on
nor did
jasmine if anybody at this table hasn't
had more experience with rice i'm going
to say it's cute brother to be honest
man no offense dude that's an advanced
race yeah okay yeah okay yeah
yeah sorry but um
yeah man i never had anything like that
but yeah i think
yeah i don't know i'm just happy to be
here man i i think yeah everybody does
have their own
vietnam you know in some ways sometimes
they're small and sometimes they're big
you know sometimes they're on the inside
of us and sometimes they're on the
outside yes i was uh
one of my kids came home and this was i
was still in the navy at the time and i
came home and there was like wars going
on and there was something happening
overseas and i was trying to contend
with how we're going to get
guys prepared for this combat situation
and i came home one time and
you know one of my kids complained about
something it was some kind of real
struggle i forget what it was but i
remember at first i was kind of like
what are you kidding me
we're at war
i didn't say those words i was able to
keep myself in check but what i realized
was
whatever you're doing in life that's
that's that's the that's your world
right and so when that world gets tough
and you don't know anything else man
that that struggle that is your vietnam
yeah
and that's where people end up whether
it's you know some girl kissing on you
when you're
whatever susannah dude well the tough
part was other people were watched like
the bigger boy like my brother and his
friends the bus would pick them up first
and so then it would come and get me and
so that's when she would pick me up
and
it was like my first girlfriend so i was
also like excited kind of to have her
but i was kind of embarrassed honestly
to have her like in front of i didn't
want ever i was just kind of
she was just tougher than me you know
she played i think baseball you know and
she could have played softball right
right so she just opted yeah i mean she
was doing that you know
so yeah they didn't even have that back
then so let's get let's get into uh for
the people a lot of people don't know
who you are i guess that might listen to
this podcast i know you're really uh
famous as a comedian right yeah that's
the deal yeah i'm done with the well as
a comedian man and so i'm grateful to
have that i'm i'm happy to be here today
with you guys man you know i really am
thank you for having me so you grew up
where were you born i was born in um
louisiana i was born in louisiana
and uh covington louisiana so
not a real part i mean it's a good place
we have tallest statue of ronald reagan
that's cool and um he's never seen it
but we got it
so if there's ever like what's the
connection with me
too so like homeless dudes are always
trying to like get in there and ship his
thumbs off and
and you know uh get the reimbursement
but uh why why reagan is he connected to
that town at all they just somebody dug
him somebody that had enough copper
enjoyed him and i think donated it to
the city
to be honest no your dad was like a
older gentleman when you were born oh
yeah
yeah my dad was 70 years old my dad was
born in 1910 and um
and he was from nicaragua and he was uh
so he was a senior citizen when i met
him you know
so eddie was from nicaragua yeah now i i
i saw that he was from bluefield
nicaragua yeah he's from bluefield i've
never been there but i heard a lot of
i've heard it's a tough place to be
sometimes because of their politics but
i heard it's really nice i heard that
and i don't know what's so what's your
dad's like background was he from there
because i guess this place was kind of
settled by european pirates
have you heard this
yeah i don't know my dad was doing his
younger i don't even see any other
pictures of him so i don't know eye
patches
yeah i've never seen him you know
hanging out with a parrot i've never
seen any of his
you know past work when i knew him it
just you know it was just a lot of
stories and
there was more like the stories by the
time i met them and stories you know
they
they get barnacles on them over time
they gain traction they get tread they
get
they take different avenues and so by
the time i knew them it was more
i was kind of left with the
you know just the stories you know the
refined stories you know
um what do you how do you end up in
america
i don't know man
i really don't random and those are
things i wish that i'd have been able to
know better and i think those are things
where sometimes like for me anyway where
i feel disconnection sometimes
is not having had that you know some of
those types of conversations when i was
old enough to kind of care
you know um
and yeah when i was like 12 once i got
like 12 or 13 i kind of i was like
i mean it was kind of embarrassing
you know having such an older day my dad
would fall he'd be asleep at like a vent
he would fall asleep at the um
carpool when he'd come pick us up he'd
fall asleep and so
the lady had to go wake him up it was
always like so much extra stuff that you
don't think you have to do as a kid just
a lot of like oh
you know
yeah so um but yeah he was cool though
man it was also interesting
you know he knew a lot of people were
about to die everybody introduced me was
about to die so
what was the deal with your mom like i
mean he must have been some kind of a
you know he must have some
cool characteristics
because how old was your mom my mom was
32 when i was born and he didn't have
any money
so i don't know who would bang an old
dude with no money bro that's insane
that is pioneer woman
i know one
i mean that is a pioneer woman you want
to talk about a pioneer woman was he a
woman or something was he super like
he had a comb i remember that he kept in
his pocket maybe he was pretty dope
he had a nice one of those small combs
men used to keep
and they still keep them in cuba a lot
of time you see a lot of cuban men still
got that small comb on them
then you think that might have been the
critical factor for for your mom looking
at him thinking damn look at that cone i
think in a small town you know it's just
that something like that could stand out
was your mom from covington louisiana
too she's from illinois so she's just
real hard-working lady
you know my mother really likes to work
hard and she's
oh we delivered newspapers and stuff
when i was a kid and delivered all type
of stuff
um
oh she used to deliver cookies for a
little while for some company dude and i
go lay in her car at night and just lay
on to on the box and just eat them
[ __ ] right just
just imagine being almost as big as the
box and you're just laying on it and
you're opening up
and that's my vietnam you're in the dark
you're trying to be quiet dude and
sometimes they would tape them extra you
know and you're like i'm gonna be all
right
and you just fall you get in and you're
just as many cookies as you could have
man you're laying on them your mouth's
laying open on them like chocolate chip
cookies nah these i remember the ones
they had were kind of uh
a hard kind of yellow cookie with a bit
of uh
kind of this granulated sugar kind of
square it looked like glitter on the top
oh yeah yeah the shortbread one i don't
know
i was excited about your story like i
could picture that but i i just don't
feel like choc i feel like
cookies
there's chocolate chip cookies and then
everything else is kind of just not in
the same ballpark
i don't know if i'd agree with that sir
i mean we don't have to agree on
everything i'm just giving you my
perspective yeah no one i appreciate you
giving it to me man
and i would probably
i'd watch you with a chocolate chocolate
chip cookie i think you know
i'd watch it i wonder would be fun to
watch you eat you know
i don't know a mango i better be pretty
funny i don't even like mango huh oddly
enough then that would make it better
for us no i in fact i don't really i've
like i grew up my we didn't have a lot
of money when i was growing up and so we
ate a lot of hamburgers right
like in the morning i would have a
hamburger on an english muffin and for
lunch i would have hamburger on bread
and then for dinner i'd have a hamburger
on a bun so you get you know all meals
could be burgers
but i didn't really i didn't even like
steak until i was maybe like 22 or 23.
oh yeah yeah because it just it just
didn't taste good to me i mean i would
think why not just grind this thing up
and put it on and put it into a patty
yeah yeah
so i don't know maybe it's funny to
watch me eat a burger on a muffin for
breakfast yeah i could see i think that
would be a unique show watching strong
men eat stuff that's a little bit more
dainty
you know maybe have a petty for some
kind of a unique a delectable you know
kind of a cookie from another country or
something
i can see that
you can't even manage it with your
fingers you know it's almost like a
grenade almost to a regular guy
you know uh did your mom and dad stay
together
they stayed together for a while man
they had four children and
um
[Music]
and then i don't know what happened i
don't know what happened and that's kind
of when i started to become like
mentally
you know aware of my world and
yeah at that point my dad was older he
didn't live with us and then
um
yeah we just had four children and my
mom was working a lot and that's where
we were so your mom basically ended up
as a single mom yeah she end up as a
single mom and
and yeah and i don't know i i i
i you would almost i don't know what you
would expect kind of having a child or
children with the older man
you know what kind of expectations you
might have um
but
but i don't know you know i don't know
what kind of comfort she needed in her
world maybe she needed to have a family
i don't know what she needed at that
time
but um
yeah so they had they had children and
then my dad was kind of gone and then i
got a little ashamed of my i got
embarrassed a little bit i was just at
that age i think where children get
where they're if they're not like other
children if anything's out of the norm
then they feel
like something's wrong with them or they
feel just embarrassed i'm sure you've
seen it with your children was there a
time where they get embarrassed yeah it
doesn't i don't think it matters if
you're uh you know like tom brady your
kids are going to be embarrassed
or like dwayne the rock johnson your
kids will be like oh here comes the big
idiot again like i don't think it
matters who you are there's going to be
your kids are going to go through an age
period where they're embarrassed by you
yeah and then you got to kind of like
just work through it i guess
and hopefully you come out the other
side and they realize oh you know that's
not too bad
but i guess the weird thing you said
like your mom's expectations i mean the
fact of the matter is
he's 70 yeah you're born i mean
expectations are
they're not even expectations facts are
he ain't going to be around all that
much longer right you know yeah she's
going to have a time off yeah
that's a limited time that's got an
expiration date on it so she signed up
for because she kind of signed up for
that activity yeah
yeah and i think and and i think when
sometimes i it's hard to not hold that
angst when i look at my life in places
that were uncomfortable for me as a
child like um and i'm not complaining
i'm just trying to share some of you
know share what
some of that was like for me but um
yeah i think there was times where it's
like uh
you felt like you weren't part of a plan
like nobody planned
or if you were it was a plan that was um
destined to fail you know what i'm
saying and so then that almost makes you
feel like
well what's going on if my
commander-in-chief here my mother or
something
set me up in this plan that doesn't seem
like it has
statistically just doesn't seem
super smart no no no now how old were
you when you started having thoughts
like that
i was it's you know
that those are kind of thoughts when i
was a kid like i was just thinking you
know machine gun throwing rocks uh you
know taking apart
pieces of furniture yeah i mean just
talking ignorant stuff
and it seems like you're sitting here
thinking about the grand scheme and all
these plans like how how old were you
when you started going down that road i
don't think i was i think i was older
when i when i started realizing that
stuff okay so this is like looking back
yeah a lot of that's looking back um
but i think at the time i'm dealing with
the ramifications of some of that
without knowing it
without always wondering well what
why do i feel certain ways or why do i
behave certain ways
so like a subconscious that's probably
just that probably just a subconscious
feeling of man this doesn't seem like
this is gonna even as a little kid
you're like man we're eating ramen again
right who came up with this plan right
yeah there's just no plan like mom's
working there's no
dad's so old so you start to get
concerned for your dad's health then you
have this weird uncomfortable thing
where you're supposed to be kind of a
child and be free to just not have any
worries but you have these weird extra
worries of like you know your dad is
getting older you know and so
i remember being like eight years old
and walking to church with my dad we had
a church a few blocks away
and
he would ask me what the
where he could walk and stuff because of
the sidewalks in louisiana
the the roots come up through them just
like kneecaps just like you know you got
a thousand long-legged men buried right
there under the sidewalk you know
and some of them's you know
you know they just it's just real femory
along those side you know the sidewalks
will do a damn they'll be in a damn
trapezoid or something half of it dude
if you take the sidewalk honestly it can
take you more time to get where you're
going you know what i'm saying the
street is the sidewalk's like the oregon
trail bro
there's natives under part of it i mean
it gets real dicey
so i remember walking with my dad and
he's like can i walk here and stuff like
that so then you're i remember getting
in this weird space of like um
just hyper concern in awareness that's
what i think it was awareness
so then i had a lot of awareness
so did that lead to uh you said
behaviors what kind of behaviors do you
think that there's a situation where you
were you acting get in trouble in school
were you you know turning into the
delinquent kid were you trying to work
real hard to make sure you always had
money i mean what what how did you react
to this situation
well i think looking back on it and it's
interesting because in my life right now
i've been doing a lot of work on this
kind of stuff specifically like trying
to just
just get enough comfort in the sediment
or those sedimentary layers those real
like just those deep layers it's hard
for me to plant roots i notice in my
adult life and i think it's because
something's the soil is just
it's just not enough room in that soil
from when i was a when i was younger
and i wouldn't care if i was able to
plant things in my life that would be
able to grow effectively but i've had
trouble doing that like relationships
commitment to things wanting to start
like a family or have a relationship but
struggle with it
so
i'm sorry this isn't very funny dude i
feel bad guys you know the one day i
mean everybody on y'all show somebody's
dying or you know somebody got naded out
bro and then i'm supposed to come in and
have some relief and i'm sitting here i
don't think there's there's no one
really that tuned into my podcast that's
expecting or anticipating or it's going
to be let down if they're not you know
if there's not levity in the situation
it's okay you don't have to be funny
here you can just talk about just mayhem
and death as far as i'm concerned we'll
still be good to go
okay
okay good yeah i think so um
one of the things that i would note that
i noticed now looking back is that i
didn't
whenever i realized that that was my
life situation that my dad was real
older and that my mom was working all
the time
i didn't believe that the world was a
comfortable place for me so as a real
young kid i just
there was enough elements in the
atmosphere where i just made that choice
as a my spirit made the choice whatever
it is something inside of me
it wasn't a choice i made like i would
make a choice now
it's like i don't trust the world to be
a safe place for me
so
whatever brought me into this world
whatever the elements are these are not
trustworthy elements um
and not that i would treat them
untrusted not that i'd be mean to them
but just in my spirit knows
that you have to take care of yourself
so
then you start to try and manage
everything yourself um
so i was always really concerned with uh
the only thing i had left then like
people would look at me you know what
the bus dropped me off like in the poor
neighborhood and my dad was so old and
my mom was always gone working she
wasn't like a mom some of the other kids
had
so
um
so the only thing i could control was me
how you saw me that was it the only
piece of my image i had was
what you saw of me so
i would like bike to school so i didn't
have to get off the poor bus i would
like um
befriend certain kids so you thought i
was in a certain group uh
i just
i was hyper concerned with kind of image
management because it's all i had left
you know i wouldn't i've tried not to be
seen around my family i kind of
because i just didn't want
i don't know i was just hyper concerned
with the only thing that i had that i
still had control over was
my own
image really and this doesn't make any
sense yeah it makes sense but it's like
this is something that you're realizing
reflectively looking back like at the
time you were like you weren't
consciously saying oh i'm i'm
embarrassed so i'm going to do this you
were just like man i don't really want
to get on that bus or get off that bus
so i'm just going to bike to school that
seems like a smart thing to do
right i think but i start to had i had
so much awareness i think i just so
aware always and so then
um
you know i just i think i was making
choices that i didn't want people to see
me a certain way how am i going to be so
then i got stuck in this
how can i manage what people think of me
so was the was the was the image that
you wanted to project because you could
see there's plenty of people that
they're in those kind of rough
situations and there
you know some people go all right i'm
gonna get straight a's and i'm gonna go
to a good college i'm gonna do all this
other stuff or some people well i'm
gonna become uh
you know i'm gonna become a the toughest
delinquent that there can be and people
are gonna be scared of me so you know
you get someone going towards like the
gang life or whatever what was it that
you were kind of moving towards were you
an athlete were you playing sports
yeah we played some decent sports in our
neighborhood dude and it was real dicey
bro we had a lot of people man we had
one dude who would sneak my we'd play
football and he'd bring matches with him
and burn you while he was doing defense
bro and that's crazy when you're
thinking okay who's guarding me you know
thomas this kid thomas dude he's just
matching you down
you know if you're not making cuts real
hard so
just some [ __ ] like that man we played
in this one field that had a big hole
right in the middle of it theater not to
the middle but off to the side with this
church football field man
and uh damn people would go missing in
that [ __ ] son you know i mean there's a
couple they had a family of 11 that i
swear to god after a long game was a
family attend uh
they lost somebody in their little
jennifer somebody
but i remember they were dude i remember
they would make girls they would put
them on the football field playing
football just in the neighborhood spray
paint a number on this one kid's back
just all kind of [ __ ] man fun stuff
though looking back
what about organized sports in high
school did you play i got into that when
i was 11. i got into that when i was 11.
so
yeah i think one thing we just were
around our neighborhood a lot we get we
get home from school and we would just
be up to our own devices you know um
but one thing i started to notice was
like uh
i didn't i had a real untrustworthy
relationship with the world so
i was always worried about i think what
people were thinking of me and i felt
like people didn't like me
i felt like i think because sometimes
i don't know if i was just such an
uncomfortable kid sometimes the
i needed laughter so
i always felt like if you were laughing
you couldn't dislike me and laugh at the
same moment
like at that moment like
it was down to that moment like when you
were done laughing
i didn't know what you thought of me you
know it was kind of scary because
um i think i didn't think much of myself
and so
the only
way i had to feel about myself from
moment to moment was how other people
felt about me you know
if i'm real honest and so
um
so i think that's why i needed laughter
because it was like oh man if i can get
it was the only thing i trusted is that
there's no way somebody could be
laughing and i could see them laughing
and having joy
and
[Music]
and hate me at the same time you know it
was just
so that was like
that was the only equation
that made
that to me was undeniable and i think
that's
and i was a hyper-sensitive kid you know
other people aren't as sensitive and so
they're able you know they can manage
things better i was hypersensitive you
know um
so i'm really grateful that god gave me
whatever i needed to be able to find
humor you know um because there was
other kids in my neighborhood and in the
environment that
that in my family didn't get that and so
it's
and i'm not trying to get any self-pity
i'm just trying to share what i'm
thinking
and feeling at the same time you know uh
and a lot of this is stuff i've been
working through recently like in the
past few weeks pretty heavily and so a
lot of it's real fresh on my brain as
well you know yeah well it's scary about
well not scary from your perspective is
the minute someone stops laughing you
just want to try and make them laugh
again so you can get that get that
get that good feeling back
yeah well it's a safe feeling i just
need to it's like man this is a place
where i feel okay if they're laughing
you know um
so yeah so i think and i wasn't like a
goofy dude i wasn't like farting in the
pudding or anything like that you know
i'm saying i wasn't some
you know booty creep or something
i just liked saying things and and i was
real aware so i would see things kind of
going on
i think i was real aware and so
so it was fun to be able to get people
to laugh at moments if you didn't think
they were and then you start managing
laughter because
laughter becomes
your main
tool that you have to feel okay and so
then you start using laughter almost
like you're calling plays and stuff and
you have these little
those are my weapons you know that was
my knives that was my fists even you
know i wasn't
i didn't have a lot of physical
confidence so
so laughter was it really for me that
was my biceps you know
it seems like too uh there's a
opportunity for someone that's in your
position where you have this kind of
like insecurity and kind of a little bit
of a paranoia against the world
to go down the path of like drug and
alcohol abuse and we all know where that
path ends up if we stay on it
so how did that enter your life i mean
what about there had to be drugs and
alcohol down there what was
what was that like what was that
influence
how how did you manage that part of the
world
yeah you know that's interesting you
know i have family members in my own
close family that have suffered with
addiction and stuff like that um
and i really love and i also love
thinking about this kind of stuff like
this kind of stuff for me talking about
feelings and stuff some people say well
you know feelings is the past and
actions is what matters and that's true
i believe that like
i can think all day and it's probably
not going to help me act any different
and i know in my own life if i do act a
certain way my thoughts will follow me
my thoughts really are your troops
really you know uh
um they say in a lot of
recovery rooms that
you can't think your way in the right
action but you can act your way into
right thinking it's a common term and
it's easy for people that struggle with
addiction or addictive personalities to
understand that it's real simple
so
sorry what was the question i felt a
little bit nervous just just as far as
what you know how old were you when
alcohol got introduced how old oh yeah
oh dude i remember i found some liquor
on some
uh
alas a liquor or something
peach mango starburst baby breath
watermelon something dude on the top
shelf dude it was nine different colors
bruh and i found some nudie mags up
there too same time titty literature
so next thing you know dude i'm
ejaculating and just just i remember
falling off the shelf i found them like
i never made it off top shelter there
about four hours here i've never been on
the top shelf you know i don't come from
a real balancing family
so i'm up there dude i'm drinking i'm
[ __ ] masturbating you know and i
remember just blacking out and falling
off that shelf
and i probably fell man
i bet six and a half feet almost eight
feet so not far how old are you at this
time oh i was probably about 13 you know
and so then but i had other family
members who were struggling with drugs
and alcohol so i had this
really i didn't see that
uh
i didn't see that as like a
a way for me to get in a thing like i
didn't see that as an escape really from
me
so i never used that as an escape um
but as i got a little bit older in my
life i i started realizing that i was
uncomfortable uh
and i was some of the survival
techniques i'd used as a child weren't
helping me anymore
um
[Music]
you mean even the comedy piece even
making people laugh did that start to
wear out
well or what survivor was the only
connection that i knew so i had a tough
time making real connections with people
especially women if i wanted to be in a
relationship or
or even i think sometimes friends or
knowing that a connection was safe like
sometimes i'll overdo a connection
somebody will say
yeah everything's fine man we'll be
there and i'll still be hyper worried
about it you know when it's fine it's
somebody else that's totally normal but
um
because somebody some connections
with people are always feel real new and
scary to me i think i was just scared to
make them um
so anyway i started realizing i was
having trouble making real connections
with people
people would say man i feel like i don't
know you but i feel like i would be
sharing a lot of stuff
uh
and so then
i i got in to i started going to some
recovery meetings 12 step
and i couldn't relate to the drugs and
alcohol but i could relate when people
talk about how they felt
you know just uh
just the feelings and so
i started learning about oh other people
feel some of these ways and it's okay to
have feelings or to struggle with them
and whatever and so that's when i really
started to like being a part of recovery
and there's all types of it you know i
mean there's stuff for everything
there's recovery for people that wear
shirts that don't fit or that fit too
tightly yeah
and uh
[Music]
zone just [ __ ] pick up a couple extra
smalls dude the sad part is there is a
small boy out there somewhere right now
you don't have a [ __ ] you don't have a
shirt
have we talked about that before taco
did we talk about that talk about what
somebody with a small shirt uh i don't
know if we talked about that so yeah so
i think that's where i found 12 step was
interesting and then it was pretty that
was later in life right yeah that was
later in life so for a long time i think
i just i chose comedy because it
doing stand-up comedy it's like a
lifestyle of disconnection you're in
town for four or five days and then you
go so if you have a relationship
starting you're like oh you know gotta
go to
chuckle willie's over in tacoma you know
and so it's like you're out of town and
then and then you're in a new place
where you can have some you know it's
like
the
the moss of life never has a chance to
grow on you really
you keep out running
the moss really
and the moss is things that
that
are real or you know or barnacles
anything that you just you just evade
things enough
and comedy just offered me that i don't
even know if i wanted to be a comedian i
think i wanted to not have to be
somewhere
so what how old were you when you did
your first you know got on stage and did
your first stand-up
gig let me think man
it was rwanda dude i think it was
2001.
it was midnight
and i was in a
i think i was in a foxhole or falcon
nest or something i don't know what was
happening we couldn't see
we got a bad batch of banana taffy from
a local
[ __ ] was dicey
there were fire
fire ants
there was a there was not yeah not
firefight there was actual fire ants in
the hole
yeah um no sorry i'm just trying to
um
trying to make you laugh a little but
was it local
oh yeah i went to a school when i was oh
i remember
well the best thing was just at the
lunch table with your friends and i
think that's the thing you're always
chasing as a comedian is just being in
an environment where
you're just making your friends laugh
you know um but i went to a class in los
angeles a lot of people don't even know
that i went to a class like a comedy
class yeah like when you see written
like just like putting those cheesy
orange letters on the side of a strip
mall yeah i was always wondering who
signed up for those things there you go
apparently they work
dude and it was so weird that there was
some guy that worked speaking of
autozone yeah totally it was your future
employment homes
oh yeah dude i think the class was even
sponsored by like a pet boy or some
quick oil offering outlet
so man we were
in the class and it was but the
interesting thing about the class was it
was not very i don't know if it was
helpful it was an environment where you
were joking around
but the thing was at the end of the
class you got to perform on stage at a
real comedy club
so that was the thing and they taped it
for you
and this
now everybody's got tape this back when
that limited amount of tape yeah
so you had a tape baby you had that
cossette though you know and so i
remember
i got up there and you had to do three
minutes and you were so nervous but then
you had a tape and so then you felt like
oh i have a piece of proof you know
and then after that they had a comedy
room near me this gentleman had half a
limb
and he was
uh
he was missing part of his leg i think
or he said he was so he could have been
faking it
cgi or something
i don't know what his name was
i mean it was a
cj it was a white dude okay
but uh
anyway
yeah he opened up a comedy room about
two blocks from where i was living in la
and i went over there on wednesdays and
and there was a couple times where i
quit i moved back to new orleans and
they had a comedy room there how are you
making money when you're working at i
mean this guy's is he even paying you or
are you paying to get to perform are you
paying him oh there's times a lot of it
was bring her
you got to bring people and if you don't
bring enough you have to pay
so that was part of it man that's that's
an under that's a dirty
sub culture business of uh comedy
did you say bring or show what did you
say yeah they call bringer shows
and you got to bring people with you and
if you don't bring like five people and
then
you know probably ten dollars to get in
or something then you have to pay that
the difference but on the 50
damn so
so this is that's where you start in
comedy that's where it's at yeah that's
really where i start and now and
honestly man when i started i knew i
i knew that i was doing pretty good at
it when i started i knew that i could do
it i knew that i could do it
and then once the lifestyle came along
where you got to scoot around and
be any place that i didn't have to make
a real connection which i didn't realize
wasn't a strong suit of mine really i
didn't really realize it at that point i
didn't really realize i was
evading something i thought i was going
towards something
and i think it's probably like that for
a lot of us in all types of
jobs
you know sometimes the field i'm chasing
it's
it's not so much something that i'm
going for as if i can figure out if
there's something that i'm trying to be
away from you know and i mean that's
just for me i don't know if that's
really for everybody in the in the seal
teams we used to say like
well you know if i mean things get bad
you know just go on a trip get on that
plane
everything's for everything's gone no
more problems you're in some new place
everything's great now yeah that was the
that was the deal you know so whatever's
happening you know you'd have some guy
living out here in san diego he's having
problems with his wife or his girlfriend
or whatever cool going on a trip
down a plane no problems anymore they're
all gone similar thing yeah evading the
problems
yeah and i was and i didn't
yeah and i didn't know i was doing that
you know i just didn't know and then
also you're out there you have you were
able to establish brief relationships
you know one night stands you know a
little bit of sex here and there a
little bit of touching jerking off next
to someone not even sex
sometimes or even just
jerking off by yourself and wishing
somebody was there
you know which is really one i mean that
was that was probably two out of three
times yeah
you mentioned
lately like only one of those sounded
like a relationship the other one's out
in like perversion and the other one
just sounded lovely so i don't know
where's
you know you're kind of getting a taste
for maybe what a relationship could be
but if you got a good imagination dude
you could have a real dime right there
with you you know and i was strong bro
in the freaking
in that middle freaking cauldron i was
really running some strong soup
so
so you would you'd be out in l.a how
long you got out in la for i've been out
there you know i'd be out there for
months at a time yeah and what would
make you would you just run out of money
and be like i'm going back to louisiana
yeah something would be uncomfortable
i'd have a long term i had a long-term
relationship for a little while which is
like the closest relationship i could
get into was having one with you know
thousands of miles of space in it and um
yeah so i i
yeah and then comedy but comedy kept
doing good it was like this thing
and when i look back i really think it
was something god that just
you know god just wanted to keep taking
care of me you know even though i think
when i was young i always
when i didn't trust the world i didn't
trust god i didn't trust that anybody
had like was looking out for me what
what years is this
it's probably 2 000
probably 2 000
now i know about 2016.
i would say
2007 so during this time you're
like what's the progression once you
would you do good with uh
bring or show once you get good at that
like okay now you're almost always going
to have people coming in
at what point do you at what point are
you you thinking yourself all right i
can i can live i can make i can pay my
rent i can get food
from
comedy
right well i got i got a credit card
that's at what point okay when i got
that credit card boy that delta reserve
they hit me up in the mail bro you know
and i looked at some of the planes
online i said these people are doing
well i'm open account with them
so i went probably about 30 something
thousand dollars in debt
over probably about four years which was
a lot of debt when you never have had
you know three thousand dollars in a
bank account so for all those years are
you paycheck to paycheck yeah just
paycheck to paycheck maybe you have 800
bucks in your bank account maybe you got
a thousand maybe you did a good show and
you maybe got 1400 but then you got to
buy a new freaking whatever
uh uh yeah the next flight was the big
experience was that next flight
so this is a struggle
it's a struggle and it start it is a
struggle honestly and i look i know it's
it's a it's my own struggle it's the
struggle in that sense i'm not other
people have way bigger struggles
but it's uh but that's the struggle part
of that job at a minimum it's a
financial struggle yes and you're are
you looking at it thinking well i'll be
doing this for the rest of my life like
for the rest of my life i'm going to be
sitting here you know going from town to
town
making 480 one night is that how much
you make when you're one of these level
comedians
no i think at that point if you do a
feature weekend somewhere you can get
paid six hundred dollars for about five
shows but you have to buy your flight
so that takes three hundred and if you
eat on eighty this is what you're
looking at anything about mixed martial
arts
uh besides ufc
like when you're young these fighters
got trained a ton of fighters that's
what they're doing
they're going to fight in nebraska
they're going to get paid 200 to fight
two hundred dollars if they win and the
flight out there costs freaking 800
bucks and they got to pay medical for
their checkup it's a freaking disaster
yeah they're killing this is the same
thing right it really is man i think it
really is too at the end those guys are
carrying it they have two of their teeth
taped into their belly buttons they
don't forget them yeah it's dicey uh
yeah it's just that circuit it's that
circuit it's the circuit of that thing
and it's um
the benefits are the things that keep
that are kind of nice and especially if
you don't know
if other people are settling down
getting married your friends getting
real
jobs that seem more real on paper
and those things
are
i didn't want to be like everybody else
that's the thing i always remember in my
head i just didn't want to be like a lot
of people
i wanted to manage my image the only
thing i had was
everything else in my life since my
birth felt like it was like a sentence
like this is who you are
you are
somebody who
you know you're not going to be in a
home where you were really loved you're
not
you know things like that i'm not
complaining i'm just sharing what i felt
like and some of this might not even be
real that's the crazy part of some of
the stuff it could be in your head
but it to me it was very real
um so the only thing i could still
control was
what i what you saw me how i
what i was
you know and i was just gonna hold out
to try and be something
i i don't even know if i knew what it
was
but i was just gonna hold out so when
you're a comedian making six 600 for
five shows in a weekend that you had to
pay 740 for your ticket to get out to
wherever you were
the what what is making it
at that time because i think it's
changed and that's where i was trying to
wonder what time like nowadays you know
there's different avenues since uh what
social media is out there and you can
use that avenue youtube you can use that
avenue there's a podcast you can use
that there's all these different avenues
but
you go rewind
ten years
like there's none of that oh you can't
make a living from youtube wasn't even a
thing yeah social media is nothing so
you're just just freaking comedy club to
comedy club
what was
quote making it back then okay did you
get a did you did you see that as a
possibility
i got three thousand i remember they
gave me three thousand did the comedy
central like ten minutes or something
and they give you three thousand three
thousand dollars for comedy central yeah
you do ten minutes they give you three
thousand dollars yeah the big ass
network comedy central that's like these
fight organizations that's the exact
same thing man it's the exact same thing
it was the ultimate fighting kind it was
the ulti it was comedy it was just it
was like obviously it was just a
different day it was just a different
dana white or it's just a different
organization you know
but then also they had all the eyeballs
then they had the eyeballs
and so yes you got a little money and
then you start to get a little notoriety
from the deal from like you could show
people oh i really am a comedian that
was that's the scariest part as a
comedian
because you're a comedian
and then do you can tell people you're a
comedian but it's a real weird thing to
tell people until you have some proof
that you are a dude because unless not
you could be a just a
just a yeah i'm a comedian for all
practical purposes right well i'm a
comedian you could be a murderer a
computer dude better suited to be a
murderer than a comedian but it's all
good dude definitely man and i always
loved peeping tommy man
since i was a kid dude i love peeping
thomas that's really uh not one of the
best things to talk about on the podcast
if you want to maintain you know
yourself not being in prison
look i'm a recovering freaking pt your
baby you know
but that's one thing neat about recovery
and being in the circles i have friends
that are flashers dude i have friends
that have done i mean i have friends
that have just
gone and knocked on the devil's door
dude and waited there until he opened it
you know what i'm saying bro and the
devil works
overtime so rarely is he home he's
24 7 opening that door up so if you're
people milling out there just hanging on
that freaking welcome mat
so so comedy central you got to get
money and now you're kind of i mean
other comp coming up
yes but also other comedians you're kind
of like elevated right yeah you started
to get elevated you're sort of the man
yeah a little bit you get enough that
boost that then it tells you okay this
path is starting to choose you there's i
think there's a unique moment in
different paths where
you're you're you're you're putting
yourself into the path and then the path
is also saying hey
you know putting its hand out son
and i do believe that for comedians man
at a certain point it kind of chooses
you
so once you do comedy central now are
when you're going to a comedy club are
you headlining now
you have a credit you're getting close
and you're starting to headline and then
you get like 1500 a week
so that's when you can start to save a
little money and um
and you're not selling tickets though
you were just most people are coming
there's a few people coming to see you
maybe 10 15 people but also back then
the
the clubs had all the email lists they
were the gatekeeper so they you know you
don't have all that you can start to put
it together we'd put the cards on the
table fill it out and like but then
you're coming before you have to do that
and i did it all man put the boxes with
the cards are you do you have a manager
or whatever like that thing is yeah you
have a manager that helps you through
the agencies to get booked yeah but you
don't have they taken their cut yeah
they take their cuts so you're getting
1500 bucks and they're taking 150 150.
and then the agent would take 150 and so
then you're down to 12 there
but
but yeah you're still grinding and i
still didn't have any other
in life there's only so you you
i find you i'm either doing something
that i want to be doing or i'm attaching
my life to other people and maybe
starting a family kind of there's not
really a ton of different things
to do you know
really i mean you just
so i i and i didn't have anything on
that other side of the coin i didn't
have any place where i felt like i could
make a commitment or start a family so
i'm like well this is this shoe just
fits so well right now how how many days
a year are you touring at this time oh i
did man i probably did 48 weeks a year
i toured hard man i toured
i toured hard man
i really didn't sometimes and here's the
crazy thing this is one thing i noticed
about a brain or somebody that has
has maybe
issues with
alcoholism stuff like that my brain
forgets that
my brain
forgets all that i did all that work
so my brain every day has this weird
governor in it that's like man you
you got to do something man you know you
haven't done anything you know i got
this weird
and i sometimes i don't know where some
of that comes from and
and those are things i still want to
figure out in my life you know where
does that come from you know some of
those things so
those are things i love kind of thinking
about and talking with people about is
like um
yeah where do these weird like
this weird legal system that's that i
built into my soul
where is that where does that all come
from and
and it's interesting you can figure some
of the times you can figure some of that
out by talking with other people about
uh that sort of thing anyway what do you
feel like the prosecution and the
defense are are arguing over with the
legal system that's in your head
but the prosecution is always just a
never there was never like us
a base foundation that i'm okay
so when i don't have that then anything
else
has a really good chance of infiltrating
and getting really into me because there
never was this
like i had a friend one time who just
texted me said hey man you're okay you
know just out of the blue
and because he knows we talked about
stuff he's in recovery and
man that [ __ ] just hit me like never in
my life had i just heard that or and it
just came through in a certain way where
i heard it i was like oh man and just
i'm just like ball i'm just like
so i think just when you don't have that
weird that foundation of that anybody
just telling you that or the world or
just like you feeling it you know then
you feel sometimes you always will feel
susceptible
to any other
well then of course you have to build
your own
thing in your head that's like you got
to get going you got to get you got to
pull yourself up by the bootstraps you
so you do that
but then after you're doing well even
that thing's still going on that's a
childhood system you put in that [ __ ]
is loose dude and that [ __ ] is out
there [ __ ] partying's got tits dude
you know what i'm saying it's turning up
and it's [ __ ] dude and it just
doesn't there's no control but that
thing has been with you for so long
that it's hard to get new systems in
place to stop those survival things
because something had to be in my head
to tell me to keep going you know uh
but as you get older it's just still
running on the same childhood system the
same original dos or whatever microsoft
dolls
so
did you ever have a point where you're
like
in freaking
whatever upstate new york you just
performed in front of seven people that
were talking while you were up on stage
and you then you had to pay them money
and you're like you know what dude i'm
going to get a job at mickey d's
did you did you have that oh
uh doing tacos selling mexican food to
people
and i'd sold all kind of food to people
over a restaurant and stuff like that i
used to sell
i sold mexican food to people when i was
younger too but did you ever have a
point where you were like yeah i gave up
at that point there was a point where i
gave up oh you gave up on comedy at some
point yeah i had this girl i was in this
long-term uh relationship and i went
back to new orleans and worked at a bar
and we was selling mexican food to
people
above board it was legal [ __ ]
and uh
and they had a
margarita machine in there and i was
working that bad boy you know and just
doing what i could
and then i some guy came in who worked
next door and he said like one thing to
me and it just
set me off like treated you like a chump
or something yeah treating me like i was
somebody that didn't
it was like some rich dude some rich you
know second-hand generation rich or
third-hand generation rich you know
somebody look i'll say this somebody in
their family probably had some cotton on
them okay
and i was more of a polyester bad boy
you know what i'm saying i was one of
those [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
those synthetic fabrics dog okay racism
free daddy okay
so this dude he said something yeah and
it just
oh and his family partially owned the
place it was a business next door they
sold wine
like gary vee or whatever guy's name is
jerry v telling people to [ __ ] sell
their home and sleep in their yard you
know what i'm saying and that dude was
raised on a damn wine
wine farm or something dude he said that
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying dude
hiding grapes in his ass at night
freezing grapes and [ __ ] hiding them
in his ass
and he's telling people how to struggle
dude that guy had his mind he's like oh
damn dude oh you still have silverware
in your house [ __ ] sell it and then
he shows up and he'll like hug the dude
the guy can't even he has no way to get
food in his mouth you know
the guy's [ __ ] just knuckling through
some chowder knuckling through some
booyah bass and he's like no worries he
made 76 last night and he hugs him you
know what i'm saying he's like what the
[ __ ]
and then he drives off and the family's
just standing there in a park
another winner
i got out of his [ __ ]
mind dude
and he hugs oh you sold two extra
christmas sweaters you didn't need from
last year and they're crying together
like what is going on dude
um
but anyway i don't look man i gotta give
some love to my boy
i'm sorry the videos i'm not saying the
guy's not a smart guy
the videos though and the guy it grew up
well off
well no i think he actually didn't grow
up well off that's part of his that's
going to be lying no you partially lying
but it's not really lying if you don't
know but he was he grew up you know his
dad owned like a corner liquor store or
something and he did you know he got
after and created the uh but in my
neighborhood a corner liquor store is
the same as a winery yeah
so if you're looking at it from maybe
from theo vaughn's perspective oh yeah
he grew up like big time oh yeah look at
these dudes over here huh
slanging that riesling
so this rich dude comes in he says
something to you he said something and
that night i broke the margarita machine
i set that [ __ ] on and broke it
and i knew that cost him probably about
and that was it and i didn't go back
there man and then i went back to la and
i was kind of yeah i didn't want to be
yeah i couldn't commit to the
relationship i was in and i just went
back to la and so
and then things like i started
i don't know what happened then but i
started picking up some steam and that's
when pod some podcasting started
and um
and i just was really fortunate man you
know my producer nick davis who's a
great guy is a huge fan of yours and so
you were gracious enough to come on and
rogan had me on his podcast at the same
time and
a couple of other little things happened
where
suddenly i kind of had a fan base i
don't know if there was much space in
between oh i did a netflix special that
didn't do anything
then wait what came out first the
netflix special yeah okay so that thing
came out but it doesn't really matter no
one really notices it did nothing man i
was so excited i remember i went to
chattanooga i'm all fired up and i'm
thinking it's gonna be packed man and it
was a small it wasn't even a big club
and there was nine people in there damn
so when stuff like that happens
that's gotta be tough to power through i
mean when you're especially with
everything you've said so far tonight
about
wanting people's laughter and approval
and all this stuff and you can release
the netflix be special
and this is
what do you think man bro i'll say that
for somebody named echo you don't even
repeat much dawg
oh dude
i'm
glad you could laugh at this
oh yeah that's painful oh it's painful
bruh but when painful here's a crazy
thing about painful man
when most of what you know in your life
feels like painful then i think [ __ ]
like that just kind of [ __ ] fits on
the ship so how are you how are you so
for other people right because other
people are having their chattanooga
experience where nine people show up
they're having you know whatever
happened in their life what did you do
because here's another thing when you
were talking about gary vee and i've i
people will assess this about me too
because it's like hard work hard work
hard work and i just had this
conversation with someone the other day
they're like you know yeah at my company
hard work doesn't necessarily mean you
get promoted i'm like that's true
everywhere hard work doesn't necessarily
like you can't just expect oh i'm just
gonna work hard work hard work hard and
that then things are just gonna happen
if that if it was i hate to say it if it
was that easy and a lot more people do
it not everyone do hard work but a lot
of people would do it a lot of people
would start working hard but you gotta
have like i'm sure you've seen comedians
along the way that were really hard
working they're sitting there they're
doing hey i wrote another 19 jokes
tonight and you read them and they all
suck right so when you get done with
this netflix special you're all amped
your expectations are so high
you show up there's no one there
how do you how do you power through that
how do you get through that what do you
do i don't know i made up with this big
thick girl i remember that
okay bro can we get some like something
a little bit more than thick girls
making out okay
i mean that's how uh you know i'm sure
you've been there dude being from the
islands or whatever
so yeah man i mean it's like i freaking
did it you know i remember yeah well
that was the end that was an interesting
thing about comedy clubs it comedy
club's just a bar it's a bar hook to a
stage so it's like then there was always
a couple you could always get a couple
drinks at the end of the night to kind
of satiate yourself and i was never a
big drink i'd have maybe two drinks you
know but um
but after that i don't know i started to
get
you know i don't know really what
happened i just knew that that wasn't it
that holly oh somebody wrote an article
i remember right when my special came
out and
it said like uh
oh this would be donald trump's favorite
comedian or something it was like a
negative it was i think it was right
around the time maybe when some of that
campaigning was started or something
and it was
and a lot of my stuff is sarcastic like
a character also it's me but it's also
this it's a
a caricature of like where you're from
right right right it's a mix really
right
and
that made me really not trust any of
like hollywood tabloids any of that kind
of [ __ ] so
and it just was so debilitating you work
so hard and somebody just does something
just completely errant and aimless you
know um
when you watched your own netflix
special
were you like oh yeah oh were you kind
of like damn
are you neutral
i felt
okay about it i felt like i went too
fast during the material i felt like i
was probably a little nervous and went
too fast
so i never really looked back on it
super fondly
but
but then at that point things started to
evolve and some podcasts and started
going
from my perspective
so
i didn't know who i i didn't and this is
it's funny because as i was like reading
about your background and trying to
figure out because i thought you just
like everybody thinks i thought oh he
just made it famous overnight or
whatever that's kind of and i didn't as
i researched i was like oh this dude's
been doing comedy for like whatever two
decades or a long time yeah about 17
years
and
there was a video it was free connor
that little video that you made you know
what i'm talking about free code yeah
dude with that bus yeah yeah
that greyhound dude yeah we just had a
greyhound driver on the podcast man
because i used to go hound all the time
dude i go on there somebody freaking
somebody's like you want to see
something it's always their dick on
there you know what i'm saying bro it's
like come on bro so
so do you pull his dick out of a hat you
know like how do you even get your dick
in a hat you know that's supposed to be
a rabbit
just a lot of freaking [ __ ] magicians
man out there bro
so i saw that thing and and it just i
was dying and laughing i kind of shared
it with all my friends because everyone
kind of likes mma and here you were
talking about
you know bust and every and kind of my
generation did win on greyhounds right
so we kind of knew i don't think a lot i
mean
in california like no one takes public
transit so it's different but across the
country man you've been to a greyhound
station
or
you've seen some you know you've seen
some [ __ ] man in your life if you've
been to grave you've been to a girl yeah
dude i saw a lady drinking a can of uh
baby formula dude
yeah you said that on that video i
didn't even know what civil act was i
thought it was some kind of drug
that's making me think i had to google
it man
so so you did that
uh you go on rogan for the first time
and this is what i wanted to say is that
when
i i think you had like a or you have and
still have like uh
like a
vulnerability and honesty about yourself
that i think
is really different
and i think that that is what makes peop
makes people made me the first time i
heard you i was like oh yeah he's not
he's exposing himself you know not not
in the way that your friends do whatever
the flashers are that you're hanging out
with but exposing yourself
so i think that was a huge thing that uh
i think p a lot of people connected as
soon as they kind of heard you and heard
you talking to joe and and freaking joe
i mean obviously his his podcast is so
massive and and he's such a good guy and
you know was telling everyone oh yeah
this guy's hilarious i mean i remember
he told i think he told me yeah he did
he was like well that guy's freaking
hilarious you know i was like hey dude
have you seen this similac thing or
whatever whatever brought it up he's
like oh that guy's hilarious
so
so then you when did you start your
podcast
i started i did a podcast with a friend
for about probably two years that was
about more like interviewing people that
was in hollywood my friend worked at tmz
and we tried a podcast together and it
was fun but i didn't get to be myself i
had to like it was more interviewing
you know and i didn't really like that
as much and so then
once one day i walked out of rogans and
i said
i need to do something more like that i
didn't know that that's
i don't think i knew until i was there
and hands on in the environment that
that's the way you could do it even by
listening i didn't get the concept a
hundred percent
um
and then i walked out i said i need to
do something more like that
and so i just
started then i started one in my kitchen
and just started kind of talking about
stuff and things that i was thinking
about and uh
and yeah and it's been
yeah it's been a it's been a place
sometimes where i share maybe more than
i should sometimes and i don't realize
it um
it's been a lot of different things man
um
sometimes it's been a blessing because
it's the
it's like the thing that keeps me going
each week it's like a guaranteed thing
you know the longest relationship i've
had in my life sometimes is with my
podcast in a lot of ways it's the one
thing that i'll show up for every week
even
um
even on times i noticed like i don't
feel good like the past maybe two years
i haven't felt really good sometimes i
think physically kind of i don't know
what it is i'm doing like a lot of blood
work and doing all these different
therapies and like
trying to kind of figure out why i don't
feel as good as i used to i physically
don't feel good
so
the hardest thing sometimes is when you
don't feel good to go in up into an
environment and put yourself out it's
like you almost want to hide from people
you don't feel you want to wake you feel
okay to get out there and like you know
so that's been one of the most
challenging things is on weeks where i
don't really feel that great
to put myself out put myself right there
it's like you just sometimes you're like
man i don't want to see people to see me
not at my best
especially when
the only thing i've always had is my own
image how you see me it's like it's it
makes it real dicey sometimes but at the
same time man i've learned a lot about
people through
podcasting you know i'm just enamored
sometimes the people that come out and
the sweet the really nice stories that
they share you know
and then people will share stuff with me
that means something to them sometimes
like
some guy came up to me this morning at
the cafe and said hey man i got five
years sober you know and
uh
and you're just so excited when you see
how somebody's life gets different or
better and
not that i have anything to do with that
i don't feel like i do but just that he
wants to share that with me and that he
feels okay sharing it you know um
things like that man it's
that's one thing i've learned i think
through podcasts and is really a power
in connect
even though it's not real human
connection it's not the hand-to-hand
combat of
of human connection because we're
through microphones and stuff
it's been surprising to me how many
people connect you know and how many
people feel
and how much feelings you can get
through stuff it's pretty remarkable
sometimes
so anyway i don't really know what i'm
talking about but
yeah it's interesting because you were
made you know you were joking around
earlier about how
you know you're sorry not being funny
right now on this podcast you're
supposed and that's what's interesting
about that is
you have some pretty serious stuff that
you do on your podcast you have some you
know you kind of sometimes you open up
about stuff and how you're feeling and
maybe it's not feeling that good
and and again i think that people tune
into that because look man if
i guess i guess i guess you could try
and like fake being funny or fake being
in a good mood but i i don't think you
can really fake it 100 where people
really believe it and i think it's
better that you
just be who you are and and you know if
you've got something if you're not if
you feel like
freaking depressed or whatever then
you're like hey this is what i feel like
right now and it makes people
comfortable that there's someone like
you who's usually funny and it seems to
have a pretty good life and all of a
sudden they're like hey man this is
freaking hard right now for whatever
reason whatever that reason might be
and
you know i i think
when people
just knowing that someone else is kind
of like there with them it's reassuring
yeah and and the other thing that's
interesting about this is you've been
saying this whole time you know that you
have a hard time with
relationships and long term and all this
but how long you've been doing your
podcast for for maybe five years so five
years
and this is the thing about podcast and
i have the same thing where
i meet people that listen to podcasts
and
they feel like we have a relationship
yeah and they're right right because
you don't get you don't you don't i mean
my podcast is three four five hours long
jesus
dude now i see what happened to you
yeah you said things probably years ago
and there's just not much in there i bet
if we tickle you we'll get them out you
creep
how often do you sit down and talk to
anyone for three hours or two hours i
walked out of europe and i remember
telling them i said hey that's the
longest conversation i've ever had in my
life with anybody especially with a man
you know like
i didn't have any male figure i had you
know there was no male
figures in my neighborhood one guy shot
up a ready med 24-hour clinic and that
was like the toughest dude we knew
you know and he was on pills so he
wasn't even really doing it out of his
own heart
so
you know we didn't have a lot of uh
i think yes i've found more probably
male influences through podcasting
um
than anywhere else in my life really
which is kind of interesting uh
you know um
and sometimes uh yeah i don't know
podcast and powerful and here's one
thing that's neat too jocko is i mostly
meet people
who i would like to meet anyway
it's like the guy that came up to me
this morning you know i would like to
meet him in you know like
he was some people it's
like i did some reality television when
i was younger you know for a couple
years on tv and i wouldn't meet people
that i didn't know they didn't know
anything about me it's just people that
see you
and that was just there was nothing to
it that meant anything really
so
to meet people you you
they know you somewhat mm-hmm and you so
you would have some common ground you
know
it's really nice almost
that's one thing that's interesting man
i feel like god has given me this weird
way where it's like
he
he always is trying to show me that
people care about me you know because i
think for so long i didn't feel like
anybody did you know when i was real
real young
and i'm not complaining you know i'm not
complaining about it i'm not i don't
need any self-pity i don't need anything
like that
but i do think it's fascinating how
you know he'll send people in every you
know every now and then somebody say
something just something it's like
it's this slow healing of this space
inside of me that was just has been
uncomfortable for a long time
you know and so there's powerful stuff
like that going on you know so
and and and sometimes i can do that for
other people
you know i know a friend of mine
he's in the military i think his dad had
some
well i i probably shouldn't talk about
maybe talking out of shop but
yeah just i don't know
i don't know man
i'm enjoying being alive these days a
lot more because i want to see what else
can unfold you know and i don't know if
i always felt like that as a kid i felt
like more like every day was a battle
you know
whereas now i'm like man every there's
there's a lot of good stuff out there
you know and i can be a part of it
whether it's for me or somebody else if
i can just do my best to take care of
myself
and keep myself
i don't even have to win every day but
dude if i can just show up and get a
strong thai dog you know what i'm saying
if i can even [ __ ] tip a judge fam
you know what i'm saying dog and pull
out that dirty w dog you know then it's
possible and i wish darren till wouldn't
have lost honestly
no homo bro
uh speaking of um
fighting what about jiu jitsu where are
you at
i haven't gone in probably about two and
a half months i just kept getting hurt
so bad who are you training with man you
gotta get find somebody that's gonna be
a little bit more relaxed when they
train with you oh dude i'm training with
locals bro dude and i was one strike
white belt man
and last time i even left because i
couldn't find parking dude so that's
kind of where i'm at right now
if that's not good
[Music]
i've been taking a lot of yoga because
some of it was my flexibility
and uh and i kept getting hurt so bad
like for me anyway i couldn't like i
needed to do comedy i was getting ready
we just taped a netflix special it's
coming out in october
this one i'm proud about
i felt excited
um
this one is more of a reflection i feel
like of
just more of a confident me as a
comedian you know so what what goes into
what goes into that
how long does it take to get ready
who contacts you like what's happening
if i if if echo charles was going to do
a netflix special what would it look
like how long would it take what would
it be
and i would bet you know no offense dude
you could be from new york
but yeah i would probably do yeah
something maybe tropical you know maybe
some ocean sounds in the back
you know maybe get that vietnamese got
to go by drinking that cranberry on the
skateboard
you know i would get it kind of you know
maybe slightly urban you know maybe
somebody playing you know maybe a dog up
near a chain-link fence in the back
and then if you can't tell jokes i would
sing dude i think he would enjoy that
there's something like watching a strong
man sing dude it's pretty powerful
it's kind of like jewel but for people
on steroids you know
stood in the rain
you're always crazy like that
um what'd you ask me man uh netflix
special so you got a netflix special
coming out so this is the last one maybe
you say you didn't feel 100 on this one
you feel 100 that's when i feel a lot
better what made you feel but what ma
how did you prepare for it
well one thing i had to stop doing was
jiu-jitsu because i kept my ribs kept
getting cracked so i it was just i mean
dude you couldn't do any yoga so when i
don't do physical things to take care of
myself i start mentally feeling bad
right
key point by the way key point for
everybody you just heard it from theo if
you
if you can't do physical stuff you're
gonna start feeling bad mentally facts
so go do physical stuff yeah i have to
and it's not even fair for me anymore to
evaluate myself sometimes if i haven't
been physically active because
i'm not giving myself a fair chance
really you know i have to be able to
take care of myself
i have to be able to be thinking with a
brain that's you know healthy so yeah so
i noticed that but anyway they gave us a
budget and we made um
and i wanted to i wanted to do one where
i felt like this one is gonna i'm gonna
do i'm gonna do right
and i got to hire the production
production company and i've gotten to go
through the editing more and it's been
tedious
but
the the months before it i had a yoga
instructor coming to my home every
couple of days
um
i was doing i had a weight trainer i had
a weight trainer
um
i was doing a lot of stuff to take care
of myself you know oh
and then where'd you dig for the
material
the material i had had about six years
to get some good material the hard part
was covered it was so fresh that 2019
the material was ready to go
you know it was just like a damn
i mean it was really just like a damn
newborn like a strong newborn you know
what i'm saying one that [ __ ] elbow
crawls out you know with a can of
freaking go in his arm you know
i don't know you know the kind of baby
that beats mom home okay like
this thing was ready to go this thing
was 10 months in the this thing was
zygoted baby um and then coveted hits
and then covet hits so then you have all
this down time
so i did move to nashville and bought i
bought a home in nashville and
because the stage was still open so i
could still go and keep this material
fresh enough
and then
i did a couple weeks in la
because there's a lot of stage time
there
about six weeks ago i went there for a
few weeks
and got it ready and
then put it down and put it down in
nashville and
it was great man like six thousand
people came out damn and uh that's
massive for comedy isn't it it's pretty
good we did three shows of two thousand
oh okay yeah right on yeah otherwise it
would be too big this venue was just
kind of real perfect enough to rhyming
over there and
um
yeah so it was good man
and it was good and i involved myself
more in the editing
you know i've seen a lot of the ropes
now i know when i can assert myself and
uh sometimes i don't do it that well
sometimes i'm too aggressive do they
record all the shows
the first one was so bad it was like
people were heckling
we built a set that literally looked
like a pedophile's uh like a pedophile
that opened a candy shop dude that's how
it was okay like was this on purpose no
no great question though
and you still don't say anything huh
okay well you know you could listen at
home man okay you're making people
uncomfortable
i'm just joking bro you seem like a nice
guy i'm just i'm just joking because i
don't want anything so you make this
sense
and it looked bad bro yeah i got there i
was so angry when i saw the set
because i didn't make it somebody i paid
somebody to make it what was the goal of
the set it was supposed to the back of
the ryman has these beautiful windows
and um
we wanted to make the windows on stage
he's colorful kind of church churchy
churchy kind of windows and
man we didn't do it dude it looked like
so did they change it that night it
looked like a gingerbread house dude for
john wayne gacy it was like as if he had
entered a sweet gba gb house contest for
he freaking got busted
if he did it
i'm saying a lot of who if he did it
um but it was so bad bro even the next
day the guy came we called him was like
get these [ __ ] things out of here and
i took one of the widows and threw it
out of the over the railing outside
piece of [ __ ]
i mean a kid could have made it look
like a kid's school thing
so the next night we just went with a
flat curtain red curtain
and uh
and we carpeted the stage which was a
little interesting i'd never done that
anymore kind of
[Music]
to take the reflection off of the stage
so it'd give us a better lighting out
some better lighting opportunities um
and then they record them all and they
recorded them all yeah and then you
depending on which night you did the
best you might take a chunk from here in
a chunk from there right that's pretty
much how you put it together it pretty
much about and we just did like
two-thirds from one show and one-third
from another
um the crowd was much better the second
night we had to get to tell the people
have security you know or just have some
control over the audience and people
wanted to be helpful you know um
and also
the uh
netflix hit us a couple days before and
said everybody has to have a test or a
pcr
you know or whatever
ppcr yeah so that was
and i'm just grateful to everybody that
came out whether they got a test or made
a fake car whatever the hell they did
dude
and a lot of people went and got the
test man and it just
it's just so nice you know um
it just it just was it's just so nice to
go spend an extra half hour the day
before you're gonna go to a show
to go and do something because you care
enough man
um
yeah
well that's awesome uh when does that
come out it'll come out in october man
and i want to say before i forget man my
friend josh colt is in the 5 27 engineer
battalion
it could be okay work go with it okay
he's a commander and he's um they're in
kuwait and they're like working in
different bases and stuff right now and
uh
i know he's got a family he's not around
i just want to tell him i'm proud of him
man and thank uh thank that whole group
for their service and uh and thank all
you guys who just can't who have to who
can't be with your loved ones you know
because i know they miss you and uh
thank you
right on uh the podcast is called this
past weekend this past weekend yep we
got
it's always nice man it's been a
blessing and this whole little universe
is a blessing and thanks for coming
through with those dimes you brought in
last night huh
that's my wife and daughter bro
cause you mentioned because you
mentioned you're afraid you've always
had a paranoia about getting murdered oh
yeah it'll go down right now
look man if anything ever happens to you
dude i will stay far away from them even
then i promise you that no beautiful
ladies it was nice to see uh obviously
they love you and it was just nice to
see a little part of your life man it
made me feel it's just inspiring you
know when i see other people doing the
things that are like seem like the
hardest thing for me to do to build for
my own future it's like every time you
see it like
it just
it makes things feel a little bit more
feasible or that i know if i need help
i can ask you or i can ask other people
that i know care so
it was it was nice i appreciate you
coming out well it's definitely feasible
it was a great show i appreciate you
being out there appreciate you making
everyone laugh
i can already see we're gonna have to do
this again we have a little bit more
time yeah i would love to i'm sorry i
have to go taking five hours next time
but whatever dude i don't know
[Laughter]
i don't know man but we got i would love
to talk more about the stuff and talk
more about um
other things hopefully i'll have some
more uh bjj training when i come back so
that would be something nice to talk
about awesome man let's get you out of
here brother echo thank you nice to meet
you brother yeah you too oh you said it
huh
the you know how you talk you mentioned
how like you'll run into people and
you'll actually have like a little bit
of a connection with them
is do you think that
like you know how you share stuff openly
more than a lot of people i think
do you think that that is an indicator
that you're doing the right thing
um because sometimes like okay so let's
say if you're in the public
light
and people will approach you or whatever
i think sometimes they can like
misrepresent who you are they're like oh
yeah maybe like they feel like they know
you you gotta podcast all this stuff and
then when they the things they say or or
they try to like relate to you or
whatever like they're just way off a lot
of the time i think not not necessarily
sometimes it can be you know but the
fact that like a random quote-unquote
random stranger can come up to you and
then you guys can relate like on a
significant like kind of deep level or
whatever just so quickly get there
that's one thing that's fascinating i
mean you could have a moment where
you're having a real moment with
somebody yeah like a moment that makes
you feel something inside of yourself
you know uh
and that's real that that to me comes
from somewhere else yeah it always like
you always struck me as someone who's
like so authentic and i think that that
that is a big indicator that you're
doing the right thing if you can really
like relate to people who you never met
before
that quickly
yeah thanks man uh yeah i i just i think
for feeling so disc it's a lot of it's
so new to me feeling connection and so
it's [ __ ] like being on a bridge that
shakes you know
i don't know what you guys call that in
you know or we usually call that a
bridge that shakes
sorry
yeah but when you say it sounds way more
technical okay it's not like people
believe it okay
um
but yeah for me a lot of that stuff is
just i'm a late
i'm a late bloomer in a lot of like kind
of i think emotional kind of ways
honestly uh
and i'm not ashamed of it or anything
like that
you know um
but sometimes in a world where you want
to be tougher
you know it's
it's uh it feels
it feels tough to sometimes learn later
in life um but yeah i think it's nice
and sometimes i don't know what
role god is using me for you know uh
you know and i just want to try and keep
myself the best
in the best way that i can so he can use
me for the best you know like um
and i really i really believe that you
know and i don't mean it in a way like
i'm some kind of hero anything i just
you know if i can take care of myself
well i believe and i believe this for
anybody that he that
or you are your higher power it doesn't
it could be whatever your higher power
is can't use you for good you know uh
and we need more good out there and we
need each other you know um anyway i
sound like a [ __ ] weirdo dog do i
sound like a weirdo
okay sorry keep being you bro nah man i
think i think echo's spot on it's kind
of it kind of mimics or or
reinforces what i was saying earlier i
think the reason that you're popular
right now is because you reveal yourself
because you're open and i think people
you're a real person and i think people
connect to that and and i think it's
awesome because i think it allows people
to connect to themselves so i say
keep doing what you're doing theo vaughn
i appreciate it man and i appreciate you
guys having me man i really do it's good
it's making me feel excited like i'm
doing the right thing right now bro bang
baby
and with that
mr theovon has left the building
he had to go
bad planning on my part
he
had a tight window i should have got him
in here earlier
didn't didn't make that adjustment so he
had to bail um
but
we're getting back
he's fired up to come back seems like we
were just kind of getting into uh some
good stuff you know so
with that it is good that theo
is you know he's on the path he's
working trying to get better trying to
be better trying to stay on the path
sober clean
fitness what was he talking about yoga
like the whole nine yards
some self-assessment going on
self-assessment happening there was some
good stuff in there actually that he
just sort of like mentioned yeah and i
was like wait wait wait did we
we could talk about i didn't want to
interrupt obviously but there's uh when
he mentioned the the thing about your
behavior and your thoughts
like your
thoughts and actions yeah so your
actions lead your thoughts your thoughts
yeah yeah the other way around doesn't
does i would say if i was to assess that
statement
i agree
your actions can lead to your thoughts i
would say more often than your thoughts
lead to actions because let's face it
gotta have some thoughts to come up with
what you're gonna do yeah
but there's a huge huge
space
between having a thought and taking
action you can close up that space you
need a lot better position
yeah and he and it felt like he was
talking about something very specific
like like basically
it's essentially like take action you
know yeah yeah
rather than just going around in your
head
and tim ferriss i think
yeah tim ferriss said that too where
essentially that different
way to say it but the exact same thing
is like get out of your head and into
your body yeah and he meant and tim
mentioned that specifically around like
getting out of depression but then what
theo was saying is if he's not
physically moving and doing work
physically he's going to be in a bad
place mentally so yeah you're right
same thing same gig for sure
unless there's a lot of stuff yes and
you can follow up on the we can follow
up on with you
and i will be looking forward to that
nonetheless in the meantime
we're all on this path together i think
thanks i feel like it i feel like we're
all sorta
when we look up we see other people on
the path with us
good feeling it's a good feeling
so
i was doing some thinking
about the bad
these okay so you when you created choco
fuel you essentially made the path
pretty luxurious because think about
when you think about like how it was
versus how it is now right yeah okay
i mean yes you are right maybe luxurious
is not my favorite word no i know you
maybe have that lingering in your brain
from
theo vaughn being on here because he and
i had had a conversation on his podcast
about
luxury days right yeah
okay so the the way to put it as far as
how you called it one time a couple
times is efficiency efficiency yes
exactly right like it's kind of like the
logistics part of a of a battle or a war
or something right where it's like yes
oh yeah you want these cool new shoes
that comfort your feet or whatever i
don't know that's the first example i
think of but
you're like
no it's not that i need to be coddled my
feet like my feet are in good shape but
i can do a lot more running a lot more
rocking you know mm-hmm a lot more
marching
yep it's insane so you kind of took that
approach yeah to the path you'll be more
efficient even though technically
speaking to support your
perspective
if you have goods and good boots for
rucking
they are technically will make you more
efficient and in some way
that is somewhat luxurious compared to a
piece of junk boots that are on bare
feet or bare feet even damn but
one could think of it in terms of well
this is gonna these bare feet is gonna
make my feet tougher
on the path when you say one could think
of it yeah
is that cause in high school they're
they're telling you you shouldn't use
you
the proverbial you in a sentence
sure yeah
i think i got it from fight club
actually to be honest what do they say
in fight club
i think he said on the plane so one
could make all types of explosives using
ordinary household items
and then the other guy said really he's
like if one were so inclined
so it's like
i'm not saying me
okay i'm saying me but i'm not saying
well it's interesting that's what you
got because i went to college and i
studied english in college and you you
aren't supposed you
aren't supposed to say
this is
you should do this or you should do that
you are supposed to say
one should say one is supposed to this
or what so right right i know to me
it's the language evolves yes english
evolves and i think we're evolving to a
point and i think i evolved to a point
where i say you right and i mean you you
you
yes
that's actually okay
that's kind of a good point
in general because ben you and i said
this before where it's it's baffling
how good we can communicate but when you
think about this all kind this is the
words you say the tone by language oh
like all this stuff is all conveying a
certain message so if you're like hey he
goes i'll tell you what you should do is
do this and then there's all kinds of
like things that you imply when you say
you you don't really mean you should do
this
you mean
a person should do this or whatever and
i know that but if i don't know that
i'll be like tell me what i should you
don't know what i should and shouldn't
do so there's a i'm
you have you specifically echo charles
have a really good point and that's why
the english language
technically in the the highest level you
should be i should be saying one should
be saying one instead of you
so
if one
i don't even know if i use that right
right there out of the gate and jamming
it up anyway if you're on the path with
you know whether you're with somebody on
the path or by yourself or you feel like
you're by yourself
it's not always going to be easy and to
make you more efficient
we're going to decrease
the beatings increase the recovery
so we can maximize gains best way i can
put it at this point gains
z
sure the so modern english okay so in
muscle building right you have the
catabolic state you just need gains
you have the anabolic state right
catabolic essentially there's a lot to
it but is the breakdown of the muscle
rest nutrition
induces an anabolic state
right we want to upside we want to
maximize anabolic state on this path
catabolic state is part of the process
as well but that trans transition from
catabolic to anabolic we want that to be
the luxury we want that to be the
efficient part of it
am i right catabolic
no bro anabolic catabolic is bad
either way okay there was a funny guy in
one of my platoons where when he would
get hungry he'd be you know he'd be
walking dude we need to go get some food
i'm going catapult right now one of
those that's why i said it that's really
leaked back out
all right well either way
we got some stuff for you all right so
chocolate fuel
let's talk about discipline the energy
drink new era new era of of energy
drinks we no longer have to pay a price
for enjoying energy drinks positivity
good tasting positive uh gives you the
boost mentally and physically positive
positive and makes you more healthy
positive
it's a healthy drink that's you you have
something that has no downside no doubt
which is kind of crazy
normally everything has a trade-off
here's no trade-off right just pure
upside just pure pure upside kind of
like salmon sashimi pure upside pure
upside tastes good good for you oh
you're better off good freebie yeah yeah
the whole side so yes
in the can
mango okay this is just my opinion okay
i'll admit mango is the best one
straight up
factually
fractionally in my opinion yep
all right either way
um either we're also free joint stuff
you you don't want to have to worry
about your joints
joint warfare
super krill oil
also vitamin d and cold water is for
your immunity so look when you consider
that these things are taken care of on
this path you are more efficient more
healthy more efficient mental physical
boosts and as you normally point out
these are things you don't want to have
to worry about correct right you don't
want to be thinking about your joints
you don't want to be thinking about
getting sick
you just you want that stuff to be
handled
handle it just handle it
that's what we're saying yep it's true
also
speaking of anabolic protein it's part
of the nutrition
profile of gains
as it were
so mulk
additional protein in the form of a
dessert another one of these up win win
win scenarios no doubt about that upside
tastes good
all this stuff tastes good exactly it's
good good for you just upside across the
board exactly right don't forget about
chocolate white tea if you're into tea
the og or the original lifting
deadlifting as well yes for sure so yes
you can get all these things at
the vitamin shop
energy drinks you can get at wawa of
course
and also everything is on jackalful.com
hey also if you wanna if you want this
stuff to come to your house all the time
without having to think about it if you
want that taken care of so if you
subscribe to any of these things
then we'll ship it to your house for
free which is amazing
and it might not be seem amazing in this
day and age because there's some really
big companies in the world that do this
but
it is amazing that you could without
ever thinking about it again
sure have super krill oil molk
joint warfare
discipline go showing up at your house
you never thought about it again you
know it just happened yeah what a
miracle
what an amazing thing subscribe
yep and life is full of these little
miracles from time to time speaking of
miracles
origin usa american-made stuff
when i say stuff because there's a lot
of stuff there's jujitsu stuff all made
in america
yep
jeans gucci
compression stuff
um originusa.com go there all the stuff
on there is american made from the
cotton that's grown
all the way up until the final
product
that's a miracle too that's my opinion
in this day and age it is a miracle in
this day and age it is a miracle to put
something on your body that is 100
without compromise made in america and
it's the best thing you could possibly
buy anyways yeah talk about upside
get the best gear
support america support american workers
is upside across the board
yeah we're working on big time upside
that's what we're doing no downside
yeah speaking of upside so i do have my
first pair of delta 68 genes
finally realized yeah so here's what
that did with the you know you know how
like you
what do you call when you build
something up in your mind and finally
when it comes you have this you know it
didn't measure up or did it not you have
the high expectations yep okay so did it
measure up here's the thing it did they
do measure up in fact they more than
measure up because you know how like
you'll say okay they kind of have a
stretch tool
cool they have a stretch to them but
when i since i don't really have any
stretchy jeans
or any jeans with a stretch to them i
don't really know what that even means
when i put them on you know
but it's nice
it's good it's like in fact it's hard to
go back now oh there's no going back
it's i'm saying yeah
so yeah dang impressive
i didn't know so much could go into g i
knew stuff goes into genes i understand
what's weird is it's hard to understand
how much better something could be yes
it's hard to imagine if you don't know
you just don't know you just hard to
imagine how much better they can be than
a normal pair of jeans yeah and again to
be made in america with american cotton
and american buttons yep
american hands as american hands
exactly right so yes orange usa.com
that's the spot right there
also
jock with the store it's called jacko's
store
so you go to jugglestore.com and this is
where you can get
i'm trying to think of a more
interesting way to to properly convey
the cool stuff you can get but at the
end of the day you can just get your
t-shirts
hats hoodies
that represent the path
i think that's the best way to put it
just plain equals freedom good take the
high ground or the high ground we'll
take you
some good stuff that's a t-shirt get
away here's what you're saying yes sir
hey subscribe to this podcast
and we also have some other podcasts got
jocko unraveling with daryl cooper we
got the grounded podcast we got the
warrior kid podcast theo vaughn has a
podcast check it out it's called this
past weekend
and he talks about stuff and it's both
funny
and revealing and
could help you yeah i like listening to
it so check that one out we're um me and
carrie were talking
during the break where theo has this
it's pretty unique quality about him
where
he's like funny but he's so authentic
and open about the even not so funny
parts of you know and i think some
people they'll try to do this and
they'll try to like
quote unquote pull it off
but
they lack the full authenticity so they
try and pull off the authenticity yes
and which is kind of what they call a
catch 22. like if you're trying to pull
off authenticity that's not in and of
itself makes it
exactly right but theo is like a
naturally well it seems natural like
he's a naturally authentic person it
sounds like from what you're saying
though he wasn't always like that and he
had to sort of open up about it over
time
okay so and this is what we're talking
about where a lot of times where
if you have the
being funny to people
legitimately is it's kind of like a
superpower like
you can essentially bestow one of the
best feelings onto a person and make
them laugh right that's one of the best
feelings you can ever have is like
laughing legitimately and
you have that as a superpower you're
just a funny person right so a lot of
people um whether they have like
internal issues or not that starts to
become the front-running quality where
they're always pushing that forward you
know they're always leading with that
leading with that and it's always
successful
meanwhile the other stuff on the inside
gets protected you know so anytime
someone feels awkward or any time
someone feels vulnerable even scared or
whatever anything that they don't like
they can just boom they can bust out the
comedy
and they'll be protected
in fact they'll get a payoff from it
they won't just be protected you know
but after a while the stuff on the
inside becomes more and more sensitive
you know where if it even if it's
exposed this much it's like whoa the
reaction is a little bit a lot stronger
you know
but theo does a good job in like opening
up and exposing that a little bit
and at the end of the day as an audience
well if i'm speaking for myself it's
kind of like you just like him more yeah
no he's a very likable guy and he part
of the reason that he's likable is
because he is like that like what you're
saying and he i even the last night i
went and saw him do his
do a comedy stand-up routine is that
what it's called
well i saw him do it and and what's cool
is like you could see
he's not um
like he's
he's real up there like he's saying
something he'd be like i don't even know
why i'm saying you know what he's like i
don't know why i'm saying this he died a
couple times today and he said i don't
even know what i'm talking about right
now he did that a couple times like okay
well at least we know that we're getting
the real a real person yeah it's not
just a big memorized script that you
know
where it's all a big uh front yeah right
we don't want the front yeah like a lot
of times if you're just talking with
your friend and you go off on some
tangent or something that's the kind of
stuff you're going to say to your friend
you know or your friends behind closed
doors you know just like in your own
little environment but ah shoot
sometimes i don't know what i'm talking
about you know but he's like so open
with that and i don't mean open like
he's like making this
huge effort to be open he's just
naturally he is like yes
he's a good good guy man i've spent some
time with him and uh definitely a really
good authentic nice funny
guy man
i really like him a lot i'm glad he was
able to come on
uh you know another podcast that there
is out there
it's called jockowunderground.com
this is the one where in the event of
[Music]
contingencies happening where the world
goes crazy er
because let's face it the world's
getting a little crazy right now let's
say it gets crazy er and they either
start
i don't know maybe they start injecting
advertisements into the middle of this
podcast or they start maybe they start
banning parts of this podcast i don't
know what they're going to do i i do
know this right now everyone's being
pretty cool to us
but there might come a time where they
say hey we don't want you to do that or
we you're going to follow our rules so
we have a contingency
in the event that that happens we have a
place to go jockle underground.com
we're building it
if you want to join it
you can go to jockondground.com it costs
8 and 18 cents a month
and for that price you give us all a
little bit of security in case the
contingencies come it's like an
insurance policy against
podcast apocalypto
and if that comes a lot of podcasts will
be like well i guess you're just gonna
have to listen to an advertisement about
a freaking mattress for
seven minutes
we're not gonna put you into that
podcast apocalypto we're gonna be there
just doing what we're doing
so we appreciate that if you can't
afford that and you still wanna be a
supporter
you can email assistants at
jockowunderground.com that way you can
get
you can get into the underground which
is where you want to be we got a youtube
channel too by the way
it's true verified by the way
for
the video version of this podcast you
want to see what theo looks like if you
don't know i think a lot of us already
know but if you don't know boom you can
see that um video
podcast is increasingly becoming
kind of the way
to to you know to watch listen to the
podcast so yeah we have a youtube
channel for that it's called jaco
podcast this is the name of the youtube
channel correct correct and origin usa
also has one if you want to see what's
going on behind the scenes up there i
also have an album believe it or not
it's almost like i made an album you
made it yep we made it collectively you
kind of made it though i just talked yes
anyways if you want to get through maybe
a temporary moment of weakness
you can press play on your mp3 player of
choice you can listen to
psychological warfare
give you a little boost give a little
help getting through that thing that's
true it's also a good way to support
flip side canvas you want to hang
something on your wall
a a a graphic image that says good
[Music]
by the way you can go and buy a fake one
from
you know one of these various places
very fake places are just jacking yeah
they have the whole good thing written
out they sell it on a t-shirt they sell
it on a print and i'm not talking about
them i'm talking about them plurally
because there's a lot of people yeah it
is weird super wack a lot of times those
though you can all you got to do is
think for one second just think for one
second like would would they really sell
this you know and then call it this it
makes very little sense oh so you're
saying it's easy to see through the the
fake all you got to do is pause for one
second and you can see it real quick
it'll say oh navy seal jocko willink
motivational shirt okay yeah that's
pretty awesome bro
i never thought of it that way yeah and
that's what they so it's like and
they're on these like
you know if you're going to whatever
freaking.net
thing that you've never heard of but
there's like generic too there's some
that you've heard of
like that that
sell these various t-shirts and posters
and whatnot yeah the only jocko shirts
official
the only place you can get them is
jacqueline's tour dot com
i can't think of one single other place
you can get them oh if you come into
victory emma man fitness you get one
here too that's true
uh so so check that out and if you want
something to hang on your wall like a
like a picture poster dakota meyer this
is his company man flipsidecampus.com go
check that out hang some cool stuff on
your wall
books got a bunch of books final spin
i don't know what to tell you we're not
even sure i'm not even sure you know you
know you you put something out there in
the world you don't know what their
reaction the reaction of the world's
gonna be might be good might be bad so
far we're doing pretty good deb
sure
dad
she's
she was she was moved let's put it to
you that way final spin i got that book
coming out
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation protocol
display equals freedom field manual
weigh the warrior kid one two three and
four get the book for the kids that you
know
just get him on the path
mikey and the dragons if there's a
little kid you know get them that book
about faced by hackworth i wrote the
forward on the new version and
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership that i wrote with my brother
leif babin
we also have echelon front
it's a leadership consultancy and we
solve problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details on that you
can also come to one of our live events
we have the muster we have field
training exercise we have ef battlefield
the next muster is in las vegas it's
october 28th and 29th
so if you want to come check that out we
will see you there
we also have an online training
situation
extreme ownership academy online leaders
of course we just we just recorded a
bunch of new leadership courses
so check that out it's like going to the
gym man you don't get good you don't get
in shape one day in the gym you don't
become a good leader one book that you
read you gotta go to the gym
extremeownership.com come check out the
leadership gym and if you wanna help
service members active and retired
their families gold star families check
out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization and if you want to donate
or you want to get involved to what she
is doing
to help out then go to america's
mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my dreary
divulging or you need more of echoes
extraneous assertions
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on the gram on facebook
echoes echo charles i am at choco
willing and theo vaughn
well
he is at theo vaughn
and thanks to theo vaughn for coming on
the show
thanks for making us all laugh there's
plenty of darkness in the world and i
know sometimes he shares some of that
darkness but in doing so he brings some
light and laughter as well so thank you
theo vaughn
and to all the folks out there
in the army navy air force marines that
are right now
right now while we're sitting in this
air-conditioned
podcast
thing
there there are folks right now out
protecting our way of life and we thank
you for it we could not do what we do
without you doing what you do and the
same goes for police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
you protect us here at home and again we
couldn't do what we do without you doing
your jobs every day so thanks to you all
as well and thanks to everyone else
that's listening and listen
we got struggles in life
we got him
and it can be a scrap it can be a fight
it can be painful
and it can be a battle but the battle
will be a little easier if you have some
fun
so when you can
don't take it all too seriously crack a
joke
have a laugh
and then go out and do what you need to
do
which is of course
continue to get after it
and until next time
zekko and jocko
out